[Musica]
vi siete mai chiesti quali sono le
risorse a nostra disposizione per
affrontare l'imprevisto
io sì mi è successo proprio di recente e
ho pensato che a partire dalle nostre
passioni che possiamo talvolta trovare
nuove energie per reagire
la mia passione al cinema e oggi voglio
parlarvi di come possa essere una mappa
per orientarsi nella vita imprevisti si
ma una pandemia è un imprevisto che ci
obbliga a sovvertire il nostro punto di
vista è come a tanti è capitato anche a
me di ritrovarmi a casa con le mie terre
bambina in quei giorni succedevano tante
cose e la mia figlia maggiore federica
si presenta con un disegno carità la
nostra famiglia così i capelli dalla
clown fanno capire bene qual è la mia
posizione in questo disegno chiedo
federica ma come mai hai disegnato così
i personaggi che poi siamo noi senza
occhi naso bocca e lei mi risponde
tranquillamente che deve ancora
esercitarsi in realtà andando se ne
aggiunge qualcosa di più interessante
quindi se papà e poi siamo tutti
cambiando in questo periodo cambiare
aiutarci a cambiare capire dove stiamo
andando e qual è la minaccia invisibile
che stiamo per combattere perché il copy
denominazione visibile da lì ho
cominciato a pensare che come da bambino
ero stato aiutato dal cinema da
ghostbusters in particolare ad
affrontare ea capire chernobyl
la radioattività invisibile anche il
copy forse poteva essere spiegato così e
allora ghostbusters diventa anche grazie
alla tuta simile a quella da utilizzare
nelle centrali nucleari è simile a
quella dei medici che stavamo
cominciando a vedere di tutti gli
operatori sanitari diventa la metafora
la doppia analogo
sia quella tra un film ma anche quella
con la mia vita quindi portare un film
per ideare un sistema non soltanto un
esempio un giorno e poi arrivederci
e allora nasce il blog nasce ma il
lovely super giro un diario aperto
avevo un eroina francesca mia moglie
medico di rianimazione
avevo un pubblico da intrattenere le
bambine e mi sono reso conto che
funzionava funzionava questo modo di
raccontare storie quotidiane inserendo
poi sempre il cinema e mi sono chiesto
anche perché ripensando a tanti
ragionamenti dei miei ultimi 15 anni più
o meno le icone funzionano sono
rassicuranti viviamo in una sorta di
giungla di icone nella nostra dello
scenario occidentale e quindi ho
ripensato a susan sontag che cito spesso
ai miei studenti alla sua suo
ragionamento degli anni 70 che paga di
democratizzare tutte le esperienze
attraverso la fotografia la fotografia
come qualcosa che ci consente di
arrivare a essere tutti sullo stesso
piano ma nello stesso tempo nella nostra
epoca diventa questa un'ansia di
accumulo perché perché abbiamo una
macchina fotografica in tasca senza
averla chiesta fondamentalmente abbiamo
lo smartphone e allora c'è anche bisogno
di riorganizzare le icone diventano da
fotografiche naturalmente
cinematografiche e questo accesso anche
illimitato alle immagini che vive l'uomo
contemporaneo porta al desiderio di
condivisione di immagini e allora
chiediamoci queste icone che rapporto
abbiamo noi con questa icona un rapporto
che rende tutto un po simile alla
hollywood boulevard la nostra vita è
fatta di una prossimità di una
confidenza che nasce proprio attraverso
lo scambio vissuto tramite un territorio
condiviso una confidenza che può essere
anche molto
confidenziale se vogliamo molto spinta
pensate se questa coppia insomma se la
gelosia in questa coppia non fosse
qualcosa di presente se queste 2 hackett
wayman non avessero il costume insomma
incontro pacifico tra individui diventa
possibile in un territorio immaginario
condiviso ma sono maschere dobbiamo
gestire questo rapporto con le maschere
viviamo una sorta di carnevale
intermittenza e togliere e mettere la
maschera diventa qualcosa di utile come
lo standard per il jazzista uno standard
consente di improvvisarsi però
attraverso una una forma già un po
conosciuta e quindi dall'icona al film
ho deciso di utilizzare sempre più
questi film che ai quali ripensavo come
degli utensili per arrivare ad avere
un'idea di mappa il cinema come una
mappa per affrontare la vita come i
giochi i giochi di ruolo i giochi per
bambini che consentono ai bambini di
immedesimarsi e di procedere attraverso
la vita avendo fatto una simulazione di
questa vita e
il cinema oltretutto vince lo spazio del
tempo e ho pensato certo però il cinema
non è l'unica forma di comunicazione
l'unica forma d'arte del nostro tempo
anche se a me piace dobbiamo fare un
ragionamento un po più esteso e quindi
mi sono tornati in mente di exempla nel
medioevo che hanno storie che avevano
questo senso di semplificazione ci
portavano a portavano gli uomini di quel
tempo a immedesimarsi e ad avere delle
guide e poi ho pensato ad altre epoche
ho pensato al vasari che nel cinquecento
scrive le vite dei più illustri pittori
scultori architetti se fosse un nostro
contemporaneo probabilmente vasari
avrebbe fatto una serie tv oggi con
tutto il successo che hanno e magari
l'avrebbe chiamata vita che vale la pena
condividere e non è stato insomma
soltanto questo ragionamento farmi
pensare all'importanza della letteratura
ma anche quello della letteratura
distopica del cinema distopico il cinema
consente anche di arrivare a immaginare
scenari possibili in modo da poterli
anche disinnescare quindi la finzione
come simulazione di esempio e allora
nello specifico come possiamo
utilizzarli questi film per far
diventare il metodo che ho usato nel
blog qualcosa di più concreto come un
cannocchiale per le metafore emanuele
tesauro scrisse nel seicento il
cannocchiale aristotelico che spingeva
ad un utilizzo molto ardito della
metafora in pratica diceva non abbiate
paura di utilizzare metafore ed è un po
stato il mio punto di riferimento per
proseguire senza timore di scomodare
grandi titoli e legati alla vita
quotidiana
le simulazioni sono andate avanti quindi
attraverso questo specchio
cinematografico la vita con tre bimbe in
casa naturalmente è piena di aneddoti e
mi sono trovato a scrivere delle lettere
aperta ma francesca che non vedevo molto
perché sui turni sono già da 12 ore
normalmente diventavano 14 15 di giorno
di notte nel weekend
è la metafora di vita ad esempio quale i
nostri minions le nostre tre bambine
sono diventate minimes i vicini di casa
a pasqua hanno realizzato delle uova
dipinte a forma di minions per diciamo
dimostrare di essere lettori del blog e
questo entusiasmo mi ha portato ad
essere in quel vortice collettivo
narrativo attraverso il quale i
musicisti soprattutto online
continuavano a esibirsi per intrattenere
in qualche modo intrattenevo anch'io ed
è arrivato inesorabile anche il dilemma
della visibilità
mi sono detto però sto mettendo in
piazza la mia famiglia e la perplessità
è stata anche quella di pensare ai miei
studenti in particolare quelli di etica
della comunicazione
mi immaginavo a casa legge nel blog e
direi una cosa tra l'altro adesso fa il
blogger e tra un po cosa farà si metterà
a ballare su tik tok
non lo so però c'erano dei motivi
c'erano dei motivi concreti a mio avviso
lo stare accanto francesca fare in modo
che lei potesse leggere queste parole e
sentire che io la stavo pensando
c'erano dei motivi eravamo tutti alla
stessa distanza i genitori i nonni delle
nostre bimbe come gli amici all'estero
abbiamo tanti amici all'estero che sono
andati a vivere a lavorare ormai
l'italia era entrata in classifica
purtroppo al terzo posto della
nell'ordine di contagi
dopo dalla cina e la corea e quindi
dovevamo raccontare quello che accadeva
e avere una rianimatrice in casa diventa
anche un motivo di ricevere domande
tanti chiedevano la cosa sta succedendo
davvero dc e ultimo ma a mio avviso
importante motivo anche essere
metaforici e rappresentare le famiglie
degli altri sanitari e devo ammetterlo è
stata anche una forma di autoterapia non
non lo nego mi mette mi svegliavo presto
nel silenzio e scrivevo nel non l'unico
momento in cui la casa è tranquilla mi
mettevo a scrivere e sono saltate fuori
anche tante cose del mio
del nostro passato le assonanze emotive
con i film hanno aiutato e quando la
mamma al mattino andava a lavorare o la
notte andava lavorare andava a
combattere voldemort
ad esempio per le bimbe più piccole
oppure andavano il sottosopra di
stringer things per le bimbe più grandi
per me era in pratica e soprattutto la
mia astronauta che usciva dalla
navicella spaziale per andare ad
aggiustare qualcosa e con un cavo dovevo
fare in modo che non si perdesse nello
spazio ma tornasse a casa e così mi sono
trasformato in arianna arianna che tiene
il il filo a teseo quando entra nel
labirinto del minotauro brescia era
completamente fuori controllo come il
numero di contagi sapete che come
bergamo sono finite sulla copertina del
new york times magazine ad esempio
e c'è anche un grande corto circuito il
corto circuito dello stato a casa
giustissimo che per le mie bambine però
era ma mamma deve uscire però quindi
questo questo slogan molto importante
doveva essere spiegato e allora il filo
il filo di arianna cercavo di tenerlo e
è arrivata poi una visibilità in attesa
televisioni radio nazionali hanno
chiamato tutti da caso ormai le case
erano studi televisivi un po per tutti
quindi anche noi ci siamo industriati e
si divertivano a rispondere a queste
chiamate via skype
la necessità però durante l'off dow di
essere una famiglia simbolica è
diventata qualcosa di più ampio non solo
dei sanitari
mi sono reso conto che tanti stavano
tenendo le redini della nostra società
chi per la distribuzione alimentare chi
per l'informazione chi per rendere tutto
possibile la sicurezza ad esempio di
quei giorni e quindi gli eroi erano
tanti e gli eroi erano in noi intesi
come società
a un certo punto però arrivata anche la
polemica rispetto agli eroi
c'è stato un momento in cui più che un
dibattito c'è stato veramente quasi una
polemica la mia prospettiva è sempre
stata quella cinematografica
non mi è piaciuto tanto questo braccio
di ferro tra eroi si eroi no l'eroe a
mio avviso è in ogni caso l'eroe
aristotelico che deve compiere un
viaggio e deve combattere una minaccia
deve riuscire a farcela come i testi di
blair di campbell importantissimi testi
di sceneggiatura del nostro settore
e allora la conferma è stata molto
importante per me sempre dalla mia
tredicenne è stata vedere che gli eroi
erano diventati suoi a un certo punto ha
disegnato i ghostbusters
ma non erano proprio basteranno i
personaggi di strange things che davvero
nella serie a un certo punto si vestono
come i ghostbusters con appunto la la
tuta la tuta che ormai ha un simbolo ho
capito in quel momento che il remake può
essere una forma di react rimettere in
scena dei modelli come si fa con i
grandi film hollywoodiani quando
funzionano bene fanno remake prima a
triscina quei modelli anche nel privato
può essere importante e ho ripensato a
uno dei dei lumi per tutti noi italiani
e non solo e tutti coloro che amano le
forme d'arte d'espressione
l'intellettuale pier paolo pasolini che
in questa pensando questi de di
stratificazione se ne andò in africa
alla fine degli anni sessanta alla
ricerca dell'autenticità di un mondo
quale mondo quello di oreste quello del
orestiade di eschilo del quinto secolo
avanti cristo
lui voleva realizzare un film dedicato a
queste tragedie e non riuscì
nell'intento ma c'è un documentario che
si chiama punti per un orestiade
africana che si chiude con la viva voce
di pasolini che disse a una nuova
nazione è nata i suoi problemi sono
infiniti ma i problemi non si risolvono
si vivono e la vita è lenta il suo il
procederà verso il futuro non ha
soluzione di continuità il lavoro di un
popolo non conosce né retorica né indugi
il suo futuro è nella sua ansia di
futuro e la sua ansia è una grande
pazienza
la pazienza è qualcosa che abbiamo
dovuto avere durante il lock down e
dobbiamo avere anche oggi
e la pazienza è quella dell'empatia
l'empatia che si è creata in quel
periodo è qualcosa da tenere accesa una
empatia nella malattia che è un po più
facile perché tutti stanno vivendo la
stessa minaccia allora per mantenerla
ho pensato di coinvolgervi e di il blog
ha avuto un senso durante quel periodo
il blog è stato importante si è chiuso
fondamentalmente come grande romanzo di
informazione alla fine del lock dow
rimane aperto posso decidere di tanto in
tanto di fare delle incursioni ma c'è
bisogno almeno io sento il bisogno di
qualcos'altro di un modo per procedere
insieme quindi voglio chiedere a tutti
voi di raccontarmi qual è il film che ha
significato qualcosa di importante nella
vostra vita e voglio lanciare un
evoluzione del blog cinema orientarsi
con i film un contenitore per raccontare
storie di persone che hanno avuto e
hanno tratto beneficio da un film hanno
avuto nella loro vita
una chiave di lettura nuova per un
problema o semplicemente hanno vissuto
dei bei momenti e hanno radicato la loro
vita all'interno del cinema
e così mi è tornato in mente in questo
scambio ermanno olmi il maestro olmi che
in un suo film del 2007 che si chiama
cento chiodi fa dire al protagonista una
frase secondo me è bellissima e inattesa
da parte di un cineasta tutti i libri
del mondo non valgono un caffè con un
amico io nel salutarvi vi auguro non
soltanto di trovare questo amico ma
anche di essere questo amico per gli
altri grazie mille
[Applauso]